hey what's up everybody all right I want
to get you up to speed on a couple
things and of course talk about the
election and who I have on the show this
week first off real quick as you
probably know at this point we are
building out our home studios so I've
got the the contractors and the builders
are inside they're whacking away at
stuff and of course I decided to do this
outside now there's a guy next door
doing construction
anyway bear with us they're telling us
that this whole build should take like
two three weeks you never know what
contractors so in the meantime we're
gonna be doing Google Hangouts new
people and my guest today is University
of Toronto professor psychology
professor Jordan Peterson who is in a
whole brouhaha as a whole kerfuffle
there's a good word for you going on
about free speech right now in his use
or non-use of preferred gender pronouns
so we're gonna get into that I'm looking
forward to talking to him and literally
hundreds of you have asked me to have
him on over the last couple weeks so
that's very cool you guys act as my
Booker's as well
all right so I just want to share a
couple thoughts quickly this is my
direct message for the week we're doing
this totally on Sprague unscripted this
time while I don't have a teleprompter
for me couple thoughts on the election
so look I was saying to everybody and
you can listen to my chat I did a three
and a half hour chat last Monday with
Joe Rogan the day before the election I
was saying I thought this was 50/50 the
whole time because I thought the Trump
base was enthused I thought the Hillary
base was not enthused and if those
people showed up then that that was what
was gonna happen now here's the deal for
those of you watching this who you dig
what I do who have heard the message
that I've been promoting for the last
year and a half against this social
justice nonsense and this collectivism
over the individual and the oppression
Olympics and all of this stuff this is
actually a win for us now let's set
aside Trump for just a second our
movement right this the things that we
have been talking about about judging
people individually not by groups and
and also just calling out the nonsense
and [ __ ] of the mainstream media and
calling out the [ __ ] of the elites
and all of that stuff and and not
ignoring the the holy middle of the
country I'm somebody that's I am from
New York and I living how
for now but I don't ignore or belittle
the people in the middle of the country
and I don't think anyone should these
are all the things that I've been taught
men and finding common ground and not
using buzzwords like racist and bigoted
and homophobe and Islamophobe and all
this stuff to just silence dissent all
of these things this was a win for us
right because if you think about it the
elite the media everybody the
establishment all wanted one thing to
happen and what did the did what
happened the people actually use their
voting power to stop that very thing
from happening that's actually beautiful
now if you hate Trump let's see what
happens my feeling is at the moment I
think there's a great opportunity here a
Scott Adams said on my show you know out
of kind of chaos and craziness is when
opportunity arises I think everybody and
I bet you right now listening to this I
feel like there's a great opportunity
right now I think there are people
coming across on every side of the aisle
right now looking around and
reevaluating everything oh and who can I
work with who are my allies who are my
friends what kind of place do I want to
live in do I want to suppress free
speech or not what do I want to do I
think there's opportunity here and I
think Trump as a populist you know in a
weird way his narcissism and populism
might work to our advantage
he's not an ideologue like he's not like
Mike Pence for example who you know as a
Christian conservative he believes
certain things about gay marriage or
about abortion because of an ideology
Trump I think is a populist he wants to
basically do probably things that will
make him feel popular and love there
might be a way that some good stuff
could come out of that maybe he'll do
some infrastructure stuff lower some
taxes there's no reason to think he's
gonna go all-in on foreign adventurous
Wars and all that kind of stuff so I
think there's opportunity here we still
have two or three months basically of of
Obama I think these people protesting
look you have the right to protest of
course I am for free speech and for
expression I don't know that you will
ever find anyone that is more for that
than me so these people have a right to
do it but you have to do it legally if
you block roads like the 101 regional
leads
my house if you block roads and all
you're doing is actually strengthening
the other side nobody's joining your
cause when you do illegal things or burn
cop cars or vandalize things or or beat
people or any of that stuff you have to
do it legally and then you have a moral
case to stand on so I think a lot of
these people protesting the road to hell
is paved with good intentions I think
they think they're fighting for the
right things they think they're fighting
against fascism were against racism or
something like that
but but it's not actually what they're
doing they're hoping they're helping the
other side so anyway my feeling is there
is great opportunity right now I think
that people kind of feel that and if the
economy gets going and Trump doesn't do
some of the more crazy things that
people think he might I think he's gonna
have to govern really from the center
and I think that will be really good for
classical liberals basic liberal people
I think it'll be really good for
mainstream conservatives and then maybe
the people that are better on the
fringes of all of this thing will slowly
be silenced that's my suspicion at the
moment and maybe I have a slight sense
of what I'm talking about cuz I kind of
saw this whole thing unfolding the way
it did by the way I'll just say one
other thing you know I we do this show
you guys fund us on patreon which is
amazing about 3,000 you and I've been
doing my Google Hangouts with you where
I do group chats and I do one-on-one
chats with a whole bunch of different
people and for about the 80 or so people
that I've talked to in the last couple
days there's a genuine feeling of most
of the people did not vote for Trump and
certainly do not support Trump but that
maybe there's some opportunity here so
let's see what happens let's see let's
not let's not prejudge let's not be
prejudiced let's judge as things happen
if Trump does something wrong that's
something illegal and moral any of that
I will be the first to hold his feet to
the fire I hope we can get Trump on the
show I hope we can get Clinton on the
show talk to any of their kids any of
that stuff
so there's something happening here I am
I'm so sure that we're like right in the
thick of it and and I'm excited I'm
actually excited so I know a lot of
people are feeling fearful right now I'm
excited for what the future can bring
I'd love to know your thoughts so let us
know in the comments right down below
and as I said a couple Google Hangouts
over the next few weeks and then we're
back in studio and we're going to
and more shows than ever will have no
time limits on on how long I can sit
down with people we've got a couple new
spin-off ideas and some other segments
and some really cool stuff and more live
streaming and all that good stuff so
thank you guys for your support and
let's see can we make America great
again without sacrificing what's been
good already let's find out
you